take two I mean some other students
underneath them do sort of an ass selfie
three pretty regularly so I'm gonna
don't as you're talking about 2k talking
about rock star you talking about fair
access and so that's I guess talk about
one of the main sort of rumors were
seeing at the moment which is red dead
redemption a remastered version of that
and Eddie where we'd wear these rumors
coming from well one of the mean that's
obvious that's one of my favorite games
of the last gen definitely something
that I'm super looking forward to the
rumors have been pretty shaky at this
point like nothing official in addition
to the remastered rumors there's rumors
of red dead redemption to write that
could tie into mafia 3 with its new
orlean setting even though it's poised
to be a prequel according to the reports
but everything is looking pretty shaky
at this point and rockstar doesn't
typically announce things at e3 in the
past they have worked with Sony like two
years ago to announce GTA 5 for
current-gen but that one seems not so
solid right yeah yummy GTA 5 they did
their own livestream thing right
Rockstar can do that time for a new red
digest I just it just seems so logical
doesn't it I mean it's still sitting it
like number three backwards compatible
like most rice like yeah that'd be great
I think that'd be awesome if they're not
remastering it but as a pc gamer i
actually missed red dead right i would
love to see it come to pay see there it
i actually was researching this LA today
there is just a subreddit dedicated to
please bring Brendan Pacey it's it just
I totally forgot about that whenever i'm
looking for like graphics for like
thumbnails or a type read that deduction
and one of the first things that comes
up is pc and it's literally just for
threads forum threads from fit so that's
the main thing like i would love a
remastered version because i just love
to see it come to pay say yeah i mean i
think you know a sequel would be better
and that's what everyone's really
excited for and then i think if we got
it if we got a sequel it'd be strange if
they not packaged it with a remaster
yeah i mean that seems to be the seven
laughing at the moment i think the other
mountain the other element there too is
we were on a take to earnings call a
couple weeks ago and they said they have
not modeled in any rockstar properties
for their current fiscal year so like I
mean
that doesn't mean it won't get an ounce
or might get an amine but it won't be
out until April 2017 at the very
earliest okay if it does that too far
away till happens wait we've waited six
years what's up what's one more you
talked about it briefly be made actually
just north of here in the Bay Area mafia
three a very interesting game sort of
interesting subject matter interesting
protagonist I mean very much a big shift
from what the Mafia games are about
predominantly guys a little bit Rafi are
like taking control of the Mafia and New
Orleans wealth wonderful sort of iconic
city to put it on and what do you think
we're gonna see of this I mean I feel
like they've shown off quite a lot but
there's not that much hyper and Matthew
three at the moment yeah this one seems
to be kind of flying under the radar and
maybe that's because it hasn't really
you know people obviously haven't gotten
hands on yet people don't really know
they don't have a great grasp or yet
which i think is why III could be a
really big show for it if they really
emphasize it more and like the setting
you know 1968 in New Orleans with the
protagonists you have the mixed-race
character and and then the soundtrack
for me is what i'm really looking for
i'd love classic rock and it's got you
know painted black House of the Rising
Sun just like a number of a number of
great songs awesome and one of the great
things about video games especially I
guess open-world games is their ability
to transport you to new place I remember
being in England and Ireland and loving
GTA because it was like oh man I means
I'm in California right you must sit
feel the same way Jess right vision felt
like that for me right like cuz I just
been to New York for the first and only
time last yeah yes like this is just ok
liked a little post-apocalyptic still
very much New York I think like the
setting for Maru 3 does sound absolutely
fascinating I am wondering if it's gonna
have kind of a the same sort of issue
that you guys are talking about with
battlefield one where they appear to be
dealing with very heavy subject yeah
yeah like they want to talk about like
one of the most racially tense times
yeah like America's recent history and
it's like I wonder how that's gonna jive
with mafia gameplay yeah for sure I mean
it's the type of thing you need to sort
of do property I don't do it all that
they're thinking about it don't like I
like it when games take the lake to try
and like take on a controversial theme
as opposed to you know dealing with
things that are more palatable yeah
perhaps watchdogs to doing the same
thing as well we talking about it
earlier range with the creative director
Tuan mafia 3 Hayden black name comes
from the Star Wars legacy dad interview
or peter has a great interview on
gamespot com where they talk about that
the whole that time period and they're
not just going there for the sake of
going there there you know trying to say
something and they're trying to say miss
marley too yeah let's talk away for
access civilizations three sorry six
something yeah it's one of those one of
those yeah yeah we're that's gonna be I
guess we we've haven't seen much of that
we saw like a trailer right right and
it's coming out in October to which is
very very soon you know one more turn
people love that franchise I was just
looking up numbers 33 million units sold
throughout the whole franchise eight
million for sip five so I mean there's a
huge install base their people are
definitely interested it's a weird
little sort of it's like strategy games
as well there's like this tiny group of
people but not tiny there's the silent
majority of people who play these games
i was looking at like steam spy
statistics for total war hammer which is
like so often absolutely i had Dave on
here before he loves that seriously yeah
so like I think in a week at two weeks
on battle born and so six times as many
copies and so I mean that's probably a
different story but like that's going to
be incredible obviously people are very
happy to see more of 66 especially some
actual gameplay since all we saw was the
sort of stylistic trailer you're looking
at now and let's talk about another one
which may or may not be on the table for
for 2k and take two at Ken Levine's new
game what is he working on you're on
that side of the world yeah so he's out
in Boston that's right around where I am
too and he's been talking about how his
this games gonna have a semi-open world
which I mean he just talks in all these
kind of vague terms but if there's
anyone if there's anyone you can trust I
wouldn't you know to pull off a vision
you know he as he has the pedigree he
has the history of Bioshock everybody
loves that obviously but unfortunately
we really don't know much about it but
III you know could be a place where they
start to talk about throwing around some
all add ways of describing this game
right like saying people don't really
want the Bioshock type like really story
heavy literary linea experience anymore
which I there really a great way yeah
of that kind of experience but he said
like he really wants to focus on
replayability and stuff price but he
says that he's like I really wanted to
be replayable but we still need to
really make a story game when we really
care about story yeah and it's also open
world and it's also a weld and he's
called it like he's it's like we're
gonna have narrative puzzle pieces so
you can walk them together a different
way so that it's like is that making
choices or is that I I don't know yeah
yeah and we also don't like know too
much about the team he's working with I
know when and you know when a rational
split up he said there were it was him
and like a handful like a small group of
people that you know stayed on so what
is the scale here is he bringing on
outside people to work with I mean
there's a lot of unanswered questions
yeah hopefully we'll see some I see some
of the monster at e3 and let's all slug
my gearbox I mean battleborn has not
worked out like it's so about 150,000 on
PC or something yeah I mean bad timing
it over watch you got to say but also
just didn't really grasp people's
attention i mean it's two concurrent
viewer concurrent player numbers at the
moment which are like you're floating a
row against team spy but it looks like
it's rent act 2000 a day like 15 hours a
day it's pretty poor it is and well it
seems that way I mean we were on that
same take to earnings call and the CEO
was saying that it's too soon to say
because there was some comments from I
think the creative director Randy varnel
right I'm who said it's off to a pretty
decent start which is kind of what a
border lands had and borderlands was
kind of a slow burner back in the day so
it it didn't it didn't start off as this
you know giant Meg hit but over time it
became that and he said you know okay
what's good to you we might be on that
path but it's it's too soon to say at
this point but the one kind of redeeming
thing about it potentially is they said
at a pact sees panel that it's DLC is
going to have hints at border lines 3 so
people might play it for that reason
there you go I mean yeah like a new
borderlands is pretty likely maybe some
you know yeah that extra battleborn DLC
will see I was entering interviewing
Randy Pitchford ash I forget where was I
think it might have been packed last
year and the I talked to my brother in
arms both his arms and he said very much
that they were going to get back into it
like you know it seemed like he wanted
to do it pretty soon and that could be
another I mean I'd love to see another
one of those house highways a fantastic
game when they came out with what was it
2013 or 20 I forget what your
when they had the brothers in arms the
Furies for right Quentin Tarantino kind
of inspired over-the-top killing Nazis
things like that I was kind of I was
kind of into that hook but they you know
they scuttled that and they said we're
gonna you know kind of reboot that could
come back with something new and they
haven't really given much about that but
that's definitely that's definitely one
of the games they I'm looking forward to
the boys main team that worked on a
couple of games so I'm sure they've got
a couple damaged slaves any fans off
evolved at the table I actually we went
into play evolve right before it came
out me den Heinz he used to work here as
rain and head and we had the best time
right it was Austin like my good friend
from cnet against like other games
Jenna's and it was so much fun like
being able to like fill certain roles
and stuff and like it relies so heavily
on you working together yeah it's like
being a good team communication can't
just be a good player to be a good team
and I think there were really promising
elements there that just didn't end up
working together also just it always
felt like the same match in the same
game which was probably you know
something that overwatch isn't running
into because there's just so many
different shoes you can feel and you
know different ways you can approach it
and it's a completely different game
depending on the heroes um I I still
think about to is going to happen I'd be
surprised if they'd be like I wonder how
like headed salad Chris waters feels the
same way as you I'm a memory and a
couple of folks in the office here
really enjoy playing together just
unlike left 4 dead 2 in which you could
they would random people and have a fun
time it just it was so irritating in the
game for so long it sold multiple
millions copies it did really it did and
the potentially more unbelievable thing
is Strauss Zelnick the CEO of take-two
had called it a permanent franchise
along with red dead and GTA so it's
something that was made it to and
they've also said well he suggested that
the first game might have been to
multiplayer centric and he wanted to put
in a little more single player in the
next one just a little more exposition
for the story and where you are like
this sweet concept I mean like being it
like it with a little crew and taking on
a huge like you know piss off month
extra stress Selma crap kicked not now
boy
I mean it's it's just a shame it's one
of those things it was just a really
cool idea and yeah a real pity you know
I heard a rock probably deserve a second
bite at the cherry anyway so we wouldn't
take away from them and then last thing
I guess to talk about would take two is
? ? ? new rock star IP it could happen
it could happen I mean if you don't tell
it was just gonna say agent so they
renewed that trademark fairly recently
but that doesn't necessarily mean
anything they're just you know holding
their rights over it but which doesn't
cost them any money right brand and it
creates another new cycle around it yeah
like oh yeah exactly good for you guys I
think people are just gonna be mad
bummed if they don't see red dead
everyone just once yeah Ted too quick
for any GTA at this stage they've said
they're working on a rockstar has
multiple unannounced new IP in
development and they haven't even teased
up anything about that mean rocks are
usually very very tight-lipped about
those kind of things and they make their
own announcements yeah and III is not
typically the stage for rock star but
anything could like anything's possible
New Warriors new bully new bully would
be great right only would be excellent
you know set in a New England boarding
school so I can relate I didn't go to
boring school I grew up in New England
good stuff there you go that's all to
take two and it's very many sub
surgeries have maybe up their sleeves
let you know let us know what you think
they're gonna answer what you'd like to
see in the comments below and hit that
subscribe button for more of our hot
rumors
you